lots of big numbers lots of big figures
and lots of big measures let's have a
look through some of them starting with
this perhaps the most eye-catching of
all the numbers three hundred and thirty
billion pounds worth of guaranteed loans
going out to UK businesses those are
loans the government are going to
support and then on top of that mortgage
holidays if you have a mortgage in if
you're affected by this no payments for
up to three months and then on top of
that you have this twenty billion pound
a package of grants and tax cuts that's
real money going out of the exchange of
in the budget this shows you the deficit
so the government's deficit how much
they're borrowing in the financial
crisis quite a high level 10% of GDP
going down downtown this is austerity
here all the way to 20 20 to 21 this
coming year and they expect it to pour
about this much about two and a half
percent of GDP let's add on that covert
nineteen measures that we had in the
budget last week twelve billion pounds
well how does today's package increase
that have a look at this will add on 20
billion pounds and you can see it's
still relatively low in historic terms
if you wanted to borrow as much as we
did during the financial crisis you're
talking about an extra 93 billion pounds
worth of boring that's what we needed to
borrow all the way back in 2009 10 some
people think we may have to borrow as
much this time around as well and how
about if you want to go even more than
that if you wanted to borrow as much as
we did during the war go on a war
footing you're talking about an extra
300 billion even more pounds on top of
that now is that pie-in-the-sky actually
some economists think we may well have
to be thinking in those terms if we're
going to confront this his Robert Choate
the head of the Office for Budget
Responsibility this is no abdication of
budget responsibility to be spending
what you need to spend to deal with this
in the best way so say some ways it's
like a wartime situation we ran during
the Second World War
budget deficits in excess of 20% of GDP
five years on the trot and that was the
right thing to do it's worth saying the
UK not the only country to bring out big
measures to try to confront the pandemic
also you have France also you have the
US
the US they're planning to mail checks
to every family in the country will we
have measures like that in the UK well
the Chancellor said there may well be
more to come
you